Hello there, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
It's a lovely sunny day,
so we're gonna mess about,
with some liquid metal.
Yeah, we got some gallium here.
This is, do you know
when you expect something
to be much lighter than it is?
I thought it was gonna be like water
and I had to lift more than I thought.
Feel how heavy that is.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
So gallium is a metal,
it melts at a pretty low temperature.
Look almost exactly like mercury,
but won't kill you as much.
Yeah.
Unless you were made out of aluminum,
and then, it would kill you.
That's true,
Yeah.
it like melts aluminum, doesn't it.
It just corrodes it to crumbles.
Yeah, so similarly to
what we did with the paint
on the speaker, we gonna
try it with this gallium
'cause I think it'll
behave quite differently.
Yeah, it should just look
like a load of liquid mirror.
Yeah.
It is a lot heavier than paint though.
So I'm wondering how it's
gonna look on the speaker.
Why don't we turn on the
Phantoms and have a little look?
Yeah.
All right.
This is so weird.
the thud of it.
It thuds down, doesn't it?
It's like, globbing, look
at that how globby it is.
You look like a DJ of science.
Science, science DJ.
Okay, we'll start low and
I'll increase the volume
and then we'll see what you want, okay?
Top.
So pay attention.
Yeah.
More than that.
Whoa.
It gets so much brighter.
Like that?
Yeah.
That's hurting my eyes, like-
It went.
I was a bit worried there,
'cause it went, huh?
It's not working, so
I turned the volume up
to try it again and it just went-
As it was all flying up
in the air, I was looking
at this and I was like, how
much of this is aluminum?
Oh, goodness me.
Stop.
Look at this.
What is happening?
That is gotta be
a compression nightmare for YouTube.
What is going on?
It looks like, evil.
It looks like aliens.
Doesn't it?
Maybe what they should
have done to the T1000,
is vibrate him to death.
Like, he would just turn into this.
Maybe they use sound guns on him.
Can you imagine if you tried
to simulate this with a computer?
Just all those infinite reflections,
reflections reflecting reflections.
I think the GPU would just melt.
It's just like, it's just a hot mess.
It's so hard to see depth.
And like, what is what.
It's almost like we're shooting
on a monochrome camera.
It looks 2D.
That's really weird.
Again, I still don't really know
what I'm looking at.
This might be
the most unwatchable
video we've ever made.
Yeah, like little solder balls.
Yeah, like, I'm just-
It's like, I'm like rolling up boogies
of gallium into like
bigger boogies though.
Look at that!
Are you having fun?
Yeah, this is so satisfying!
You have no idea, look.
Wee!
It's like a cross between
like silver and milk,
'cause it has like a skin on it of slag,
that you have to sort of wipe
off with this slag remover.
It does look like slag, doesn't it?
And you just like, wipe it clean
and it has a nice, fresh mirrored-
It's so satisfying to do that by the way.
Yeah, that might be the most gallium
I've ever seen in one place.
When we started filming today,
it was the most gallium,
I'd seen in one place.
I'd never seen gallium before.
Who's like, that's a lot of gallium.
Done it on the speaker.
It was a very hard to-
the sun's right there.
It's like someone's using their watch
in class, you know when you like
twist it around and your just like-
All right let's try a nice pour.
Okay, you ready?
Yep.
Go for it.
Good.
Think that was quite a good one.
Yeah, excellent.
How do you feel about it?
Yeah, pretty good about it.
Good pour?
I tried to grab you.
Ready?
Yep.
So, I predictably focus
just in front of that lip.
It does come out, oh
look at that shine there.
Look at that.
Can you see the camera
in the reflection of that?
I think you can, you
can see like the trees
and the sky, you can probably see me.
Three suns there turning into-
That is mad.
That is definitely how the
T1000 was born, isn't it.
It is.
He must have been cast just like this.
It looks like one it's being made.
Oh, it looks like-
Oh, weird.
It's quite thick.
Do you know when the T1000 is transforming
into like a different shape?
Like-
Yeah.
It looks like that.
They were really accurate
with that back in the day.
Oh, look at those lens
flares rippling off it now.
It's very cool.
And it's like slowly sort of globbing
into the bowl at the bottom there.
Yeah.
I like how the stream gets thinner
and thinner as it goes down.
And then it turns into like
a torrent at the bottom.
Look at that!
Look at that on the right-hand side there,
where it's all bouncing up.
Maybe we should go in tight on that area
and just get one more pour.
Just from like in the bowl.
Yeah.
Yeah, let's do it.
Three, two, one.
Stop.
Looks like the moon.
It does, I don't know,
once again,
Like what are we
looking at?
Such a weird site.
Oh, oh, whoa.
That's weird.
They look like-
Diamond like-
That was a pear, that was like a plum bob
from the Sims.
Whoa.
That's amazing.
That.
It looks like something
like from Krypton in Man of Steel.
Yeah.
I'd wanna reverse it
and see what it looks like to,
it looks like it's
sucking up all the energy.
Weird the way it breaks
up differently to water.
Like, it's too heavy for air to get under,
so it stays as like cones.
That was a cool bit.
It's just not really bouncing.
It's sort of just falling into,
it's just like really heavy water.
Yeah. It's all like kicking
out in the middle of it
and now it's, cause it's deeper,
it's like, because it's so heavy,
it's forcing all the
other stuff to the side.
It makes these weird
vertical ripples coming out.
There's like all the horizontal ones,
and then you get this
vertical that's sent out.
I'm pouring it slightly forward
because that's the nature of pouring.
You can't just pour directly down
unless you're far away.
So it's creating all these
like shooting forwards
all this gubbs that's just
creating little giblets
going everywhere.
I'm always a big fan of filming liquid
but weird liquid is even better.
Mmm
Are you excited about this?
Yeah, I really am.
Oh, look at that like creme there.
Oh yeah.
That mirrored surface, look at that.
Hey, there's me, look.
Oh, I bunched it.
I could honestly film
this material all day,
until .
Okay, you may have seen this
in the background of the video so far.
We thought it'd be a good
idea to wreck this drum.
Goodbye sweet drum.
But see if we can get a
good hit from underneath.
Just like when we did that powder paint.
Yeah, except powder paint
weighs a lot less than,
you know, metal.
Yeah.
So I'm gonna to pour it on here
and obviously we're in back garden.
so it's not even completely level,
so it's gonna be like deeper
over here than it is over here.
I'm gonna have to go underneath
the drum skin with a spanner
to try and hit it.
And hopefully we'll catch most of it,
in this child's paddling pool.
Yes.
All right, probably only
get one shot at this.
All right, so the first test is to see
whether the drum could even hold
Oh dear.
this much liquid.
God, it's all pulling to the back.
So that way I get caked in gallium.
Need me to tuck you in?
Yeah, just tuck me into bed.
Nice.
That's perfect actually,
Okay, go for it.
Little bit of rain.
Whoa!
[Gavin] You see how it sends
it all out to the sides?
Yeah.
And then it hits.
That's mental.
So that's so different to,
Do you know what?
everything else we've put on.
Its is because the drum
isn't level, right.
So the way you're seeing it
ripple to and then bounce up
is the edge of the actual liquid.
Yeah, I was deliberately focused
on the front edge,
because I wanted to see
all those spikes in focus.
You see them all raise
up at the front there.
That is cool.
Oh man.
Loot at all those.
It ripples out
and then it like bounces back in,
if you know what I mean.
Yeah.
So that's what it looks
like to hit a sheet
of liquid metal from underneath.
I think I could look at
liquid metal all day.
Well not all day,
but maybe 20 or so
minutes before I go bored.
I can't even look at it now.
The sun's right there.
You're not even stood in it!
I was wondering why you'd stood us here.
I guess the only thing to do now then
is to scrape this gallium
back into a container.
Hopefully we still got enough
'cause I want to use that again in future.
That was, that was amazing.
It's pretty sweet isn't it?
If you enjoy watching liquid
metals bounce all around,
let us know in the comments,
feel free to subscribe.
Whack that picture of
a bell for some reason.
And we've got a second channel too.
See you in the next video.
You're gonna get a wicked tan.
I am, should I just stand
here like this, like-